i'm talking about a new book now okay
it's a new book it examines how
breathing and breathing techniques and
easy exercises can actually improve
improve your health this according to
new research a growing body of research
that shows that proper breathing
can help many conditions including
anxiety asthma sleep apnea
adhd autoimmune diseases hypertension
also dental health believe it or not
author james nestor writes about these
techniques in
breath the new science of a lost art
now we should point out nestor is not a
doctor he's not a scientist
however he spoke to a lot of them in
researching this book and also went
through a journey
on his own uh from not breathing too
well to uh
doing it better none of what he's about
to say is intended to be a substitute
for doctor's advice but i do think this
is going to be an enriching conversation
and james nestor joins us now james good
morning to you
um this is an unexpectedly fascinating
book i will say i had some skepticism
when i picked it up i think okay
breathing
as long as you do it it's all the same
right but you've convinced me that it's
not
that you can that there's a difference
between breathing through your nose and
your mouth for example
and that we've been doing it wrong many
of us how did that happen
how did we as big old mammals get bad at
this essential part of life
well i had a lot of skepticism when i
was first researching this book
i didn't think that there was a very
interesting story in breathing at all
until i started talking to biological
anthropologists
there are such things and they showed me
ancient
skulls and if you look at an ancient
skull
it's going to have perfectly straight
teeth very powerful jaw
forward-growing face if you look at a
modern skull
such as mine it's going to have crooked
teeth a flatter face
recessed face so when we have a smaller
mouth
and that's what's happened with modern
humans teeth have nowhere to grow
in so they grow in crooked and having a
smaller mouth
also means we have a smaller airway
which is one of the main reasons so many
of us have sleep apnea
why we snore while we have other
respiratory issues so in other words
cavemen did not snore they did not need
braces
uh and it was a trade-off our brains got
bigger
but our mouths got smaller our jaws got
smaller and now we're struggling to
breathe
so it's no one's fault we're dealing
with it how do we change it how do we
improve our breathing
well it's much easier when you're a
young kid or an infant because so much
of that growth is happening
so eating hard foods not eating
industrialized
mush because that's the number one
culprit to why our mouths have grown so
small and our teeth are
so bad but when you're in adulthood it's
a lot harder
so you can adopt healthy breathing
habits but you can also do
exercises for your mouth because what we
have here
in our throat is basically a muscle tube
and it gets flabby just like any other
muscle
and the more soft processed foods we eat
the less we're able to really have that
masticatory stress which we need
to keep this muscle fit so james you
call this a lost
art and a missing pillar of health why
aren't doctors generally
talking about this why isn't the medical
community traditionally putting this in
the forefront of healthy living
well they were for thousands of years
you look at the oldest medical texts
from
india from china even from greece and
they were talking about healthy
breathing there's seven books in the
chinese dao
that talk only about breathing all the
bad things that are going to happen
if you do it improperly and all the good
things that are going to happen if you
do it properly
so you know there's a growing body of
research it's been there for 100
hundreds of years actually in the
western cultures about how
healthy breathing habits can really
improve so many chronic conditions
but i think as new pills and other
potions came around we thought oh we
don't need to concentrate on our
breathing
we'll just take this pill we'll just do
this thing yeah but what we're finding
yeah so go ahead what we're finding
what we're finding is that you know you
really do have to show up and do some of
this work for your body to stay balanced
western medicine is a miraculous thing
that has so many innumerable benefits to
us
but breathing is something we carry with
us all day long
25 000 times a day we're breathing if
we're doing that improperly
the body is just never going to be
healthy james can i just say excuse me
james can i just say tony has been so
excited about you coming
he was saying i can't wait to talk to
him i can't wait for you guys to hear
what he has to say
apparently he talks about you at home
his wife katie purr
who works for the competition but we
love her anyway he said good evening
from my dinner table where tony decouple
is explaining to me
that our nose holes are a lot smaller
than they were
1.5 million years ago so you have
definitely made an impression james
bravo to you i'm curious is it better to
breathe through your nose or breathe
through your mouth
ah that's an easy question when you're
when you're breathing through your mouth
the reason why that is so damaging for
you is specifically because you are not
breathing through your nose so if you
were to cut my head in half and i've
seen my head
in a cat scan what you see here
in these sinuses is this incredible
volume it's this very ornate
structure so when we breathe through our
noses
we force air through this labyrinth of
all these different tubes all these
different structures
so that it is heated it is moistened and
it is conditioned by the time it enters
our lungs
so if you're breathing through the mouth
you don't get any of those advantages
and when you're breathing through the
mouth it's almost like your lungs are an
external organ because they're exposed
to
everything in the air and if you live in
a city like i do that's pollutants
that's politics you know on and on i'm
left i will always be
not a mouth breather but a nose breather
thanks to you i can't imagine what your
dinner table conversation is going to be
tonight since you've actually i met
jerry
in person i was very struck by the book
also i want to leave people with the
perfect breath
5.5 seconds in 5.5 seconds out
5.5 breasts per minute and you get five
and a half liters of oxygen
five seconds in five seconds five
seconds i know it's a long that seems
long james five seconds seems long now
there's a lot more in the book people
should pick it up it's very interesting
don't be skeptical he will convince you
and that book is breath
on sale now